The lead actor of Candyman had a not-so-sweet
time on set, but he was richly rewarded for
his suffering.
Tony Todd, who portrayed the terrifying ghost
of a man who was murdered in the late 1800s,
revealed in an interview with The Guardian
that he earned a ton of extra cash while filming
the Bernard Rose-directed 1992 horror film.
The star pocketed a cool $1,000 each time
he was stung by a bee during shooting, which
was a lot.
In total, Todd took home $23,000 in addition
to his agreed-upon paycheck for the film,
though he seemingly would have been fine without
the additional compensation, as he fully embraced
bees as an integral part of Candyman's story.
The actor explained,
"I negotiated a bonus of $1,000 for every
sting during the bee scene.
And I got stung 23 times.
Everything that's worth making has to involve
some sort of pain.
Once I realized it was an important part of
who Candyman was, I embraced it.
It was like putting on a beautiful coat."
Candyman features Todd's character often covered
in bees, but the most stunning moment happens
when a group of bees emerge from his mouth.
That sequence was achieved by placing actual
bees inside Todd's mouth, with a dental dam
in place to keep the critters from making
their way down his throat.
The bees used in the film were actually specifically
bred to appear on the big screen.
According to iHorror, the Candyman team used
newborn bees that were about 12 hours old,
making them appear like adult bees with less
harmful stings.
Unfortunately, Candyman's lead actress, who
happens to be slightly allergic to bees, apparently
went without a bonus, but she was still well
taken care of on set.
Virginia Madsen, who played graduate student
Helen in the flick, almost passed on the role
due to her allergy.
When director Bernard Rose told her that she
probably was just psyching herself out, Madsen
got tested for insect allergies, and learned
that she was more allergic to wasps than bees.
With that knowledge, Madsen had more confidence
heading into Candyman, and was comforted by
all the precautions in place.
She once told HorrorNewsNetwork,
"I really just had to go into this zen sort
of place and the takes were very short.
What took the longest was getting the bees
off of us.
They had this tiny 'bee vacuum,' which wouldn't
harm the bees.
After the scene where the bees were all over
my face and my head, it took both Tony and
I 45 minutes just to get the bees off.
That's when it became difficult to sit still.
It was cool though, I felt like a total badass
doing it."
Now that everyone knows about Todd's bee sting
compensation deal with the original Candyman
team, the crew behind the upcoming remake
might start devising their own deal with the
actor.
Get Out and Us director Jordan Peele has teamed
with Little Woods filmmaker Nia DaCosta for
a remake of Candyman, due out sometime in
2020, in which Todd is set to reprise his
iconic role.
"Jordan has such respect for the horror that's
come before, I mean two of his favorite films
are Night of the Living Dead and Candyman,
so I got a small piece of both."
The OG star is stepping up to the plate for
the "reimagining," acting opposite Sorry to
Bother You actor LaKeith Stanfield and If
Beale Street Could Talk actress Teyonah Parris.
The fact that Todd suffered dozens of stings
while filming the original means he'll probably
sustain just as many if not more during the
upcoming reimagining.
Hopefully when Todd puts on that, quote, "beautiful
coat" to play Candyman again, the remake team
can also offer him stacks of cash for any
pain that comes with it.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
stuff are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.